all the children in the state have been
wearing masks since the beginning it's
not that big a deal it'll help save
lives keep them healthy and that's all
we're asking for so there has been some
pushback but we're not backing down from
this we think it's important
people I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's February 2nd 2023. we're
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals subscribe if you have not and
today is a locals Community Q a so if
you want to see if you can get a last
second question in we will allow it join
us at
reubenreport.locals.com the locals
Community is blowing up and that gives
me a good moment to mention that I can
officially tell you that January was by
far I know I've said it a bunch lately
but it's worth repeating not to Pat
myself on the back although I can't pack
these guys on on the back for their hard
work but I think something good is
happening here because January was by
far our biggest month on YouTube alone
it was our best month I think by
64 if you have a month increase of 10
that's good 20 percent that's fantastic
30 kind of unheard of et cetera et
cetera 64 also Rumble is just on like a
hockey stick of growth right now all the
Social Media stuff people are paying
attention we're working hard I think
doing something that's relevant so
that's just a little thank you uh up top
to you guys because the the engine is
clean and effective and the Machine is
rolling so all good uh before we do the
Community Q a though I wanted to do the
story you know I don't do much about
sort of the the inter drama of the
YouTube people right I mostly stick to
politics I stick to to the culture wars
and and all that kind of stuff and some
philosophy and whatever it might be but
I don't get into like the nitty-gritty
of the the YouTube game and there's an
entire YouTube ecosystem of people that
are making videos to destroy this person
and that person counters the video to
take out this person and then they sort
of they're they're mutually assured
destruction actually makes a lot of
money for everybody because they're
getting clicks by going after this
person it's sort of like when rappers
are fighting each other you're Biggie
Smalls and you're uh give me another
rapper uh
you've got your Tupac uh he's no longer
with us Biggie's not with us either man
all my rap heroes are gone uh but you
know these guys would get go at each
other I don't know if those two were
those two were probably fighting somehow
right somebody's fighting or you got
your Iggy Azalea fighting your uh
Beyonce Jay-Z the point is they get into
these things and I'm not saying there's
nothing there but then it's good for
everybody you sell more albums you get
more clicks blah blah blah so there's a
lot of this sort of thing on YouTube but
but there was an interesting controversy
on YouTube and I wonder I'm actually
totally curious we'll look in the
comments to hear from you guys how many
of you heard about this controversy
because this is super interesting there
is a guy a young guy who goes by the
name Mr Beast on YouTube I'm guessing
he's probably in his late 20s do you
even know how how old this guy is how
old 24 wow he's 24 years old this guy
has become he's worth probably hundreds
and hundreds of millions of dollars he
does all sorts of video videos and a lot
of what he does is giving people money
he gives people money he helps people
buy houses and cars and get their life
in order he seems to be doing a lot of
good stuff from anything that I've seen
and his stuff does show up on my YouTube
feed constantly anything that I've seen
seems like he's doing good stuff that's
what I've been able to see in any event
he decided to pay
for a thousand people to get their
blindness reversed there are procedures
that can be done for a specific type of
blindness to actually get your blindness
reversed you are blind one moment you
have the procedure you can see next and
he paid and then made a big video about
it for this to happen this procedure to
happen for a thousand people and
literally all over the world he went to
multiple countries to do this it's
really fantastic we're going to show you
a little bite of it but the reason I
wanted to show you this is because there
was a huge blowback against him for
doing what strikes me as a seriously
nice thing uh it's good for him too
obviously you get some PR and he gets
clicks and all that but like using your
money for good and to help people see
seems pretty good but but YouTubers went
after him mainstream media went after I
mean it was really really bizarre so I
want to just unpack that a little bit
and then we'll get into the Community Q
a and then I also want to make fun of
Leonardo DiCaprio real quick and then
you know we'll wrap it up nicely and
you'll go about your day sounds good
okay let's do it uh real quick guys let
me talk to you about Birch gold uh you
know despite the U.S blowing through the
31.4 trillion dollar debt ceiling in
January the leftist White House still
refuses to reduce spending while our
national leadership has buried their
heads in the sand when it comes to
fiscal responsibility it's time to pull
yours out now would be a great time to
diversify into gold with Birch gold in
times of high uncertainty and
instability gold is King it's Dependable
Birch gold makes it easy to convert an
IRA or 401K into an IRA in Precious
Metals here's what you need to do visit
birchgold.com Dave to claim your free
info kit on gold and then talk to one of
their precious metals Specialists think
about this to dig our country out of
this mountain of debt every taxpayer in
America would have to write a check for
247 thousand dollars we're gonna have to
talk to Mr Beast about that and it's
only getting worse guys protect yourself
with gold today by visiting
birchgold.com Dave with an A plus rating
from the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews you can
trust Birch gold to protect your future
visit birchgold.com Dave today
and now back to me all right so this Mr
Beast fella and if you're if you're a
YouTube person one of these people that
clicks around you end up in the rabbit
holes you start watching Dave Rubin next
thing you know you're watching the Mr
Beast or something else uh he's a huge
tick tocker he's all over the place this
guy and as I said he's got a ton of
money and he seems from what I can tell
to be doing good things with his money
he's a with his money he's a 24 year old
kid he's from North Carolina he has over
a hundred thirty million subscribers on
YouTube by comparison we have about 2
million now obviously my channel is hit
with all sorts of Shadow bands and
everything else because of the politics
and that sort of thing but like 2
million and we're pretty big right like
this is we're doing something over here
and this guy's got 130 million
subscribers really nuts anyway he
reinvests all of his profits back into
each video where he performs these
family-friendly stunts or these big acts
of philanthropy as I've been saying so
now I want to show you this this is a
little compilation video because he did
a big video on this thing he did this
video where he gave this this incredible
truly life-changing surgery so that
blind people could see to a thousand
people it's cataract surgery to cure
their blindness here's just a little
snippet
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
yes seriously you know what here's ten
thousand dollars
we're just getting started we still have
980 lives left to change there's my
watch I've never seen it before all
right oh my God man
and there you go
I'm crying I can see everybody's face
will feature now it's a little blurry
with my tears coming out
okay yeah I've been subscribed to you
for like 11 years really oh my gosh
Jeremiah has been blinded his right eye
since he was born and it's affected his
vision his entire life let's do this
how'd it go okay yeah are you excited
[Music]
yeah take your time no pressure
everything looks some more clear yeah
to make this day even more special since
you're about to graduate high school and
go to college we wanted to give you
fifty thousand dollars to put towards
College
[Music]
I didn't even think this was for you
like waiting to wake up
oh my God
but we're also going to other places
around the world because unfortunately
nearly half the population with curable
blindness doesn't have access to this
surgery so I wanted to provide this to
as many people as possible
[Music]
okay
as a thank you because you were just so
gracious in this video we want to make a
hundred thousand dollar donation it'll
bring sight to thousands of people all
right so how great is this like if
there's anyone watching this I I know
you guys you're good decent people
you're watching this going oh how
heartwarming it's nice you could almost
tear up a thousand people can now see
that could not see before because of
cataracts because of what this guy did
he's also paying for people to go to
college he gave the doctor another
hundred grand but then what happens and
this is so consistent you'll see why I
wanted to talk about this this is so
consistent with everything that happens
in the world if you try to do something
good if you if you do something sort of
like Elon Musk trying to fight for free
speech then suddenly there's a Litany of
articles in every mainstream publication
about how evil he is and how bad his
businesses are and all that this kid
does this on his own volition and it
does doesn't matter if he's making more
money on these videos than he's spending
he's doing something really fantastic
but then the haters come out and there's
this this Cascade uh this endless
Cascade of people on YouTube going after
him for this he's a grifter and
everything else and then mainstream
media goes after him too check out this
article from Forbes Forbes was once once
a reputable place of Journalism Forbes
is absolutely trash Forbes by the way we
just remembered this while we were
playing this thing about six months ago
said that they wrote a whole article
about how my audience had abandoned me
because of my political positions and
literally I think every month the last
six months we've broken every record and
as I just said we just like smash them
into Oblivion anyway here's what Forbes
said about Mr Beast who just helped a
thousand people see and see and
generally thought of as a good thing Mr
BEAST's latest video sees the YouTuber
help cure the blind partnering with SE
International to provide manual small
incision cataract surgery to a thousand
patients filming their delighted
reactions in the wake of a successful
procedure however
the video sparked controversy online
igniting an interesting ethics debate Mr
BEAST's habit of showering strangers
with cash for Content has long been a
bit of a joke on Twitter because his
charitable acts tend to conceal an
uncomfortable truth under the shiny
surface the fact that these videos are
created primarily for clout and profit
imbue them with a dark undertone
especially when young fans view them as
acts of Messianic empathy after all one
can't always depend on the kindness of
YouTubers essentially Mr BEAST's videos
are much like those feel-good news
stories that hide a bleak reality at
their core like stories of children
raising money to pay their parents
medical bills or teachers having to go
to extreme lengths to provide basic
classroom supplies dystopian acts of
desperation framed as inspirational and
empowering good God where's my barf bag
from the other day because I'm going to
need it this led to some Twitter users
you got to watch out for some Twitter
users voicing concerns of their
discomfort even labeling the video
demonic and mocking Mr Beast but many of
the critiques aimed at Mr BEAST's video
were not aimed at the YouTuber but the
systems that incentivizes this kind of
content political streamer Hassan
watched Mr BEAST's curing blindness
video on Twitch and stated that watching
it made him filled with rage went
on to explain we shut off access to a
10-minute procedure because we pay
walled it and decided that some people
simply can't get it Mr Beast is happy to
take credit for enriching these people's
lives but would it be so difficult to
take a few seconds per video to explain
the conditions that led to his subjects
suffering a little context could go a
long way the subjects of Mr B's videos
are surely blessed by his interventions
but the concern is that many of the
children who watch these videos are
absorbing a particular ideology that's
the only way to change the world is to
get incredibly Rich throw some of that
cash in the right direction and make
sure there's a camera pointing your way
I must say that is one of the most
disgusting
ridiculous
moronic things that has ever been
written in mainstream media we all want
people to help you know everyone seems
everyone seems to want the government to
help maybe not you guys but like the the
mainstream uh layer of this thing oh the
government should help if only the
government could take from some and do
whatever a certain set of people want to
do to another certain set of people and
it usually hurts those people this guy
he's figured out to make
money for himself which is fantastic
probably lives a great life and he's
doing all of this good work and these
bitter quote-unquote journalists at
Forbes that they dare even print this
trash like he should have spent more
time figuring out what their real
problems are like you think that that
kid who now can see couldn't see out of
his right eye now can see who's crying
and then got 50 Grand you think he's
looking at this like oh I hate Mr Beast
it's so stupid the government literally
steals boatloads of your money to drop
bombs on countries across the world you
don't even know why
and people are upset about this thing
anyway Mr Beast saw a little bit of the
pushback and he wrote this on Twitter he
wrote Twitter rich people should help
others with their money me okay I'll use
my money to help people and I promise to
give away all my money before I die
every single penny Twitter Twitter Mr
Beast bad and that got almost uh 50
million views uh The Babylon B had a
great take on this thing because they
saw the controversy this is just perfect
sad YouTuber Mr B spends million curing
people curing blind people when he could
have sent another tank to Ukraine
absolutely perfect and I just wanted to
juxtapose this with something else
because here you have this again I don't
know this kid
it just all seems interesting to me like
I don't know 24 year old kid doing all
this good work and and that he's making
a dime on it too like it's great like
it's it's just great all around but I
wanted to compare that to uh Leonardo
DiCaprio because as you know Leonardo
DiCaprio who I'm sure is worth at least
100 million bucks and he's actually a
great actor he's in a ton of great
movies he's freaking perfect in Wolf of
Wall Street
um I even like Titanic there I said it
okay I didn't like the first time I saw
it over the years I've come to enjoy the
Titanic when it's been on TNT in the
afternoon and you know whatever I don't
have cable anymore but okay fine I like
Titanic what are you gonna do
um uh Eli David who's a doctor who does
a ton on covet he had an interesting
tweet about Leonardo DiCaprio as he
wrote Leonardo DiCaprio is very
concerned about climate change fun fact
his mega yacht emits more carbon in a
single trip than your car in your entire
lifetime now look at that yacht there it
turns out that he rents that yacht he
does not own that yacht but isn't that
just the essence of all of this stuff
this the same people who will tell you
Mr Beast is a bad dude for doing good
stuff because he's getting attention
while he's doing it and making some
money they're the same people that love
Leonardo Dicaprio and Leonardo DiCaprio
will fly on his private jets all over
the place and he will get on those
Yachts his carbon footprint will be
massive while he guilts you into not
driving car or anything else you know
when we were I saw Leo once when we
lived in La what was that you remember
that restaurant in Laurel Canyon that
little Italian joint down there whatever
that place was called remember that
place saw him down there and he was
sitting at a table he had five chicks
with him sitting there like this five
chicks arm around two of them he was
living a good life that's what I'm
saying
anywho let's get to a Reuben reports a
Community Q and A I will try to do good
work no one's getting paid I'm not
paying you people to watch but you might
enjoy yourself is that enough how about
that uh Nineveh says hey Dave I just
finished reading your second book and I
could not stop laughing if you could
choose one book to have everyone in the
world read what would it be
well first off I'm thrilled to hear that
you couldn't stop laughing at it because
my one concern with don't burn this
country which obviously was the second
book was that I did not feel it was as
funny as the first book the first book
because it was a little more
autobiographical I felt like I got more
funny quips in there my my editor like
we were a little looser with some of the
silliness and then in the in the second
book it was a little denser like it was
a little more research heavy and I felt
like we cut a lot of jokes at the end so
I'm very very glad to hear that and if
you if you read it and you liked it you
might want to try the audiobook because
that's because I do the whole thing
myself and then you know some of the the
inflection and intonation in my voice I
think you'll dig it if there was one
book that everyone could read I mean
look my easy answer on this is read 12
rules for life if you have not read it
um I I literally lived it like I lived
that book by Jordan Peterson by being on
tour with him 120 stops as you guys know
in about 20 countries for a year and a
half it was it was incredible I look
back on it like did that happen it was a
dream but that's a very easy answer for
me to give you
um I would say you know I've mentioned
this book a couple times before and it's
it's I wish I could have interviewed him
but he passed away before I was doing
any of this stuff you know the great
astronomer and science Communicator Carl
Sagan and Carl Sagan was sort of If You
Don't Know Carl Sagan uh if you're young
you probably don't know Carl Sagan
um he was he was sort of Neil deGrasse
Tyson before Neil deGrasse Tyson he was
um he was a he would go on Johnny Carson
and he would talk about these great
ideas of philosophy and Science and
Space and all of these things he was a
professor at Cornell University also
um and actually when I was on Bill
Maher's show I asked him because bill
went to Cornell if he ever had a course
with him and unfortunately he wasn't
teaching much at the time because he had
sort of become a TV star but I know a
lot of you don't like Neil deGrasse
Tyson he is certainly no Carl Sagan and
he's become sort of a crazed leftist
especially around covid but Sagan was
sort of non-political and just wanted to
communicate the decent ideas of science
to people he wrote One work of fiction
which was the movie contact which is an
absolutely wonderful movie it might be
my favorite movie ever with Jody Foster
came out in 1997 and uh and he wrote
many many books including Cosmos but his
last book was called billions and
billions and he actually passed away he
died of cancer right before he had
finished the book so his wife andreian
who's also a professor at Cornell I
think she still is now actually she
actually had to finish the book for him
but it's it's sort of him he clearly
knew that his time was coming to a close
and it's him putting his final touches
on on the thoughts of his life and it's
uh it's really really wonderful and he
had a great way of explaining really
complex stuff in a very very human way
uh James says I heard you were possibly
doing a tour in Europe for 2023 any
confirmation or teaser that you can
provide I need to plan in advance Dave
you know what I don't want to tease too
much right now because there's a couple
moving Parts here I also have to blend
uh you know there are two kids here that
I gotta feed make sure they're doing
okay change diapers and things I can't
leave everything to David so we're
trying to figure out like do we have to
break it into two trips maybe even three
trips now it sounds like uh I mentioned
yesterday that Jordan Peterson's putting
on this Conference in October uh where
they're going to really do this sort of
assault like a 180 reverse on the wef a
bottom-up idea of how to fix the world's
problems that'll be in London in October
so I'm gonna try to get to that but yes
May
there's going to be a couple countries
at least two possibly three maybe four
we're trying to figure it out just hang
tight on that I'll have more for you
soon uh Amy says what activities are you
most looking forward to doing with
Justin and Luke I mean I can't wait to
get out there and play basketball with
them like that's it I really really hope
they like basketball I know the thing is
with kids everyone throws them into
soccer at the beginning because you can
basically just stand out there and you
don't have to do much of anything in
another you know whatever Not A lot's
happening I'm not a soccer guy I find it
boring as hell but whatever what you
know I'll go out and do it but I cannot
wait to uh to teach them how to shoot
hoops like I just hope that uh you know
I'm 46 now but let's say it's in like
five years five we could start shooting
around a little bit maybe a little bit
before hopefully I'm still walking
um I cannot wait for that cannot wait
for that um I'd love to go fishing with
them too I think that'll be super fun
which obviously here in Florida plenty
of opportunities to do that um but
they're really like they're growing so
fast right now like every morning
they're both in that phase where you
wake up in the morning and I'm like whoa
you're bigger than you were before wait
you're who and who's that one and yeah
it's uh it's a lot uh and also Justin is
now he's almost into six months like
he's not quite crawling but he's rolling
like this kid can basically get where he
needs to go by Rolling which is uh which
is sort of hilarious to watch uh cool
mom says rather than encourage us to
talk politics with our Democrat friends
and family which often ends badly
shouldn't the focus be on Pros like
yourself getting the truth out is there
a plan to stop liberal views from
dominating the airwaves are you working
towards crossing over
um well if you mean crossing over if you
mean into or you're saying the airwaves
so I think you mean maybe like a little
more into the mainstream I mean look
I tried many times when I put those two
books out that were both best sellers uh
to get on CNN we tried to get on MSNBC
we tried to get on whatever the the
political talk shows are on all of these
networks nobody would have me Fox and
Fox Business would put me on every show
and they still consistently put me on
these things I would have gone on all of
these shows to talk about all these
things
um is what it is so I don't know that we
can I don't know that we can salvage the
mainstream and I don't know that we have
to you know the mainstream media at this
point it's dying in numbers it's why
they write nonsensical hit pieces why
does Forbes write hit pieces about how
Joe Rogan's a racist is it or and why
did Brian stelter for weeks cover how
Joe Rogan's a racist is it because they
really believe he's racist or they
believe that he's getting the views and
the clicks that they used to got so they
want to take him out why is it that
Forbes is going after this Mr Beast guy
is do they honestly think it's worth
writing an article that this guy who
just helped a thousand people in several
countries see some for the first time
that it's worth taking him out or is it
that they know if they write a hit piece
about him it'll cause controversy and
then cause clicks right like you know
the answer to that obviously so I don't
know how important it is to transcend
that thing the the mainstream media
seems to me at this point to be a
dinosaur in the La Brea Tar Pits right
like for those of you that have been to
LA or just picture the dinosaur the
prototypical dinosaur in the Tar Pits
where you go to your natural history
museum in whatever City you're in and
the dinosaur is slowly sinking right and
then other dinosaurs are jumping on top
of it remember they'd show you like a
brontosaurus walks into the tar pits and
now he's sinking and then some other
Predator would jump on him because he's
easy prey but then that what that guy
doesn't realize is oh man he's sinking
now the tar is on me you know a
saber-toothed tiger now I can't get out
either and I think that's what the
mainstream media is doing it's feeding
on itself in its last gasps as it as it
sinks down beneath the tar and I think
that that's just fine I think we have to
do the best we can to help convince
people that have been paying attention
to those things that there are more
truthful things out there it's what I
was saying yesterday about the view how
whether a b can we can you Google that I
don't even know that it's a thing that
we can find but is is the view part of
ABC news or is it part of ABC's
entertainment division because if it's
part of their entertainment division
then you can then just sort of
business-wise I guess you could just say
all right it's just an entertainment
show it doesn't matter what these girls
say
but at a news level and it and it in
essence is a de facto news show at this
point when these women lie about
absolutely everything
it's a real problem oh we're getting the
info right now so technically it is part
of the entertainment not news division
isn't that interesting because they know
it's not news when Anna Navarro gets up
there as she did two days ago and she's
screaming about the importance of this
African-American uh AP class uh
African-American history AP class and
claiming that Ron DeSantis is getting
rid of it because he's racist and
doesn't mention anything about
genderqueer Theory blah blah blah it's
like you are confusing people
intentionally but I suppose you're an
entertainment show so you're allowed to
do it oh interesting this is interesting
Phoenix is give me info on the fly it
was part The View was part of ABC News
division until 2014 but then they
switched it to the entertainment
division that is extremely interesting
so there may have been legal reasons for
that you know you're upheld to different
standards when you're part of the news
division than you are as part of the
entertainment industry so
there you go uh Francis says when
someone hollers for Dave in your house
do both you and Dave answer so the thing
is he goes by David I go by Dave however
my family still calls me David So when
when I have my brother and sister and
spouses and nieces and nephews all my
nieces and nephews they call me Big
Uncle David they call him little Uncle
David I'm a little bit taller uh and
depending on how much I've eaten I could
be a little bit wider
um and my parents call me David so it
can be very confusing when we have a lot
of family under the roof but beyond that
it's we're we're pretty we're pretty
good he does nobody really calls him
Dave and at this point none of my
friends really call me David so it kind
of it worked itself out I guess it is
weird like it is sort of weird I suppose
but at some point you just stop thinking
about it
um Sam says just a thought from a
California resident what do you really
think Gavin Newsom presidency would look
like I had this conversation with my
friend the other day because we both
abhor him so much much but he is a
California Democrat he has never faced
any kind of opposition at all look how
awful Kamala is same thing right because
she was a senator from Cali once they
get to D.C with actual Republicans with
power they are totally exposed like what
would Newsom do with a republican House
and Senate that he had to work with well
first off let me just say
I'm going to do everything in my power
to ensure that Gavin Newsom never
becomes president of the United States
there's an interesting conversation
happening a little bit about Gavin which
is you know a lot of people think he's
just he's just a shill like he's just a
grifter he'll do anything for power like
he's not a True Believer I know people
that know him personally and a lot of
people say he's not really a bananas
leftist right like you might say that I
don't even know that she's a True
Believer either or Bernie's a True
Believer right so Bernie whether you
like him or not I don't think there's a
lot of question as to whether he
believes in the ideas of leftism and
socialism like he does he's been
fighting and screaming about these
moronic collectivist idiotic ideas as he
became a millionaire with three houses
for many many decades like he is a True
Believer someone like Gavin Newsom and
again I know people that know him a lot
of people he doesn't believe this stuff
he's just doing whatever will get him
elected whatever will give him power so
in some ways that makes him the perfect
Democrat because you'll do anything to
attain power right and that scene seems
to be what the game is about with these
people
um you are totally right and it's an
important point that
because California has become a
one-party State he's been able to do
whatever he wants there and by the way
when he does those things he destroys
the state and his people make more money
right so you have to think about it in
like a pretty clear way you could see
the videos that I showed you guys last
week from San Francisco right and
they're they're insane they're
absolutely insane it's not a city it is
a it is right out of the Walking Dead
you could go to Los Angeles you could go
all over the state the state has water
problems because there's this kind of
constant tension between the middle of
the state and the cities all of this
stuff there's so many problems in
California the deficits the roads suck
like all of it right and it should be
the most spectacular state in the in the
union like the size of it the geographic
area along the Pacific like it's so
gorgeous the mountains like there's so
much there that you can go skiing and be
on the beach basically within the same
day like there's so many incredible
things there
but you have to understand that this guy
is doing everything for power so he
might look at San Francisco and you
might wonder well why is he letting that
happen well he's letting it happen
because when they put in the policies
that stop Builders from building or
putting all these crazy regulations it's
his guys that are making the deals right
it's his guys that are getting richer
it's the exact same thing with the world
economic Forum types do you think Bill
Gates is ever going to stop eating meat
do you think Bill Gates is going to be
eating bugs of course he's not do you
think John Kerry while he's flying
around on his plane will ever stop
eating filet mignon and foie gras like
of course they will not so these people
have they they really it is that video
that we showed you a couple weeks ago
what was it that John Kerry said he said
we're this is extraordinary we're like
extraterrestrials like basically like
we're like gods and I think that is
really what these people believe they
think it is their job to constantly be
rejiggering human society so it fits to
their egotistical old psychosis
I'm not into it
that's just me the valencias love the
valencias they say when are we going to
be able to chat with each other in the
Reuben report Community it would be nice
to have a built-in messenger feature
been waiting for this and other features
to be rolled out where's the beta test
group sign me up all right first up I
promise you you'll be in the first beta
test group we're working on it I told
you we're working on a bunch of stuff it
takes time to build these things and
there's been a lot of things you know
when we did the merger with Rumble there
were a lot of things like we had our
Engineers our locals Engineers helping
them on things they were helping us on
things we had to combine all of the
forces there obviously we opened up
Offices here in Miami and the studio in
Miami rumbles building out really
fantastic on the water offices in
Sarasota that are great there's big
things happening also then this freaking
ridiculous war in Ukraine happened
that's where most of our locals
programmers were we were able to get a
whole bunch of people out who now are
working here in the United States some
of them are still in Europe and in
different parts different countries
right now so that delayed some things
but but the feature set trust me I I've
seen the Whiteboard uh the feature set
has live chat for you guys to go back
and forth on each other we want it to be
an all-in-one Stop and Shop basically so
you guys can communicate with each other
so you can do Commerce with each other
and with us like we're figuring out all
of these things um it's it everything
takes a little bit of time uh but you
know just in terms of the feature set
like we're now live streaming on locals
that was something we couldn't do about
a month ago so like we are building this
stuff out I appreciate your patience
bear with us uh and more is coming I
promise yeah uh Rich says hi Dave so
much has been said about Elon Musk by
his supporters and detractors that he
seems to have an air of eccentricity
surrounding him he's almost Howard
Hughes minus the crazy what surprised
you the most when you spend time with
him well I mentioned to you guys I mean
the first thing was on that on that
first night when I went in there and
it's about 12 30 A.M
and he's meeting with all these people
and I'm sort of standing off to the side
with a couple of the engineers there
kind of catching me up on some of the
things that we had been talking about
for the last two weeks
um and then Elon comes up to me we start
chatting for a minute and the fact work
a few minutes and then he basically that
he said hey if you need me tonight if
you need me to stay tonight like I'm
really tired but if you need me to stay
there I'll stay like that's crazy like
absolutely crazy the world's richest man
right like he doesn't work for me right
he's got a hell of a lot to do I'm just
one guy in this ecosystem that you know
they happen to find some things on my
account that now they've found across
the board but like that he was willing
to stay at that point basically at 1am
for that and that then we push it to
tomorrow in our meeting as I told you
guys our meeting kept getting pushed
throughout the day so again we didn't
meet until after midnight and then we
had two hours but the other part that
was cool was like he's he really is like
like right when we sat in the meeting he
was in the middle of showing somebody
like a funny video online about like it
was like a mockumentary about what it's
like to raise funds in Silicon Valley
and he was cracking up and he was funny
I told you he lit up when we talked
about the political alignment because I
think he really does feel like
the sort of political Evolution that
that I've been going through for these
last couple years and definitely been on
the Forefront of talking about at least
I think he's right within that I think
we're I think there's so many people in
America just like that and I think it's
why I always even though it frustrates
you guys sometimes and it frustrates me
it's why I always talk about Bill Maher
because it's not about bills
specifically but it's about the type of
disaffected liberal that might be
willing to ultimately change their vote
when most people will not
um you know he was just a good dude he
was also like you know the second night
I know the first night yeah the first
night he was wearing a suit the second
night he was wearing a t-shirt that was
just kind of like it was just like a
ratty old t-shirt like I don't know that
I would have even been seen in that
t-shirt uh you know and just sneakers
and like some basic jeans like he's just
like a decent dude and you just have to
remember not only is he running Tesla
and SpaceX and trying to get us to Mars
and all this stuff the guy has all the
money in the world he could literally do
anything that you can think of and and a
gajillion things that you can't think of
like if he wanted to buy Bora Bora and
live in a tropical Paradise with a
hundred servants for the rest of his
life and never be seen by humans again
he could do it if he wanted to turn it
into the island of Dr Moreau and do
bizarre experiments cross-breeding
humans with elephants he could do that
maybe he is but instead he chose to get
into this fight and I don't know what
better Mark of an man you could find in
that Oak says we're 31 trillion in debt
with no end to the spending are we
bankrupt is there any chance that Social
Security and Medicare will be means
tested you know this is the debate that
we have every year about this stupid
debt ceiling being raised look we are a
debtor Nation
period we do not have any money we have
notes that say I owe you if this was
Monopoly we'd be screwed right now like
we are one roll of the dice away from
being in the Poor House on Baltic Avenue
right we're gonna we're gonna have to
basically sell crack on Baltic uh so
that we can get you know a tenement home
something like that
um so we are a debtor Nation there's no
way we're paying back our debts
obviously like there's simply no way
we're doing it and I think at the end of
the day like this is a weird depressing
reality but it's just true it's why we
have to have the best military in the
world you know if you borrow money from
somebody any mafia movie you've ever
seen you borrow money from the mafia and
then it's like you either pay them back
on time or they may be uh they you know
kind of roughed you up once maybe rough
you up twice third time you're taking a
drive out to the Meadowlands in Jersey
right and and then that's it so one day
China might be like hmm
uh well it does seem that the United
States we've crunched the numbers here
and it does seem like the United States
owes us an awful lot of money uh we're
going to call in the debt and then
they're going to call Joe Biden he won't
know where he is hopefully he's not
president anymore but but whoever they
call they call Ron DeSantis and they say
we're calling in the debt we're cashing
in the chips
and he's gonna have to go well what
do we do about this and then you either
prolong it
but how long can you prolong it for
before the whole house of cards fails or
you end up in some sort of War situation
maybe this is why we have these wars
periodically a whole bunch of people are
getting rich off Ukraine right now the
idea that we gave a hundred billion
dollars a hundred billion of your
dollars to Ukraine what why
why and we have virtually no debate
about it and if you even question it if
you even question it you're somehow
thought of as a Russian stooge or you're
working for Putin or something like that
and that's nutty but maybe the machine
just needs the wars every now and again
to keep the the money thing flowing I
think it's probably something close to
that but I don't think I don't think
Social Security and Medicare will fall
or Medicaid will fall because it'll just
kind of keep going if the machine is
good at one thing it's good it's good in
that it can keep going I think the best
we can do with the machine is at times
when we get enough Brave politicians and
I'm talking about the federal level we
can kind of push it back into a sane
Direction you can't completely alter it
I don't think you can and you can maybe
push it this way you can maybe push it
this way you can pull you can tug blah
blah blah I don't think you can do that
much
um which is why I would want that thing
to be pretty small to begin with and
it's why I would always focus on States
before the federal government Heather
yeah what's our what's our uh what do we
have right now in expenditures in
Florida we're up we have like a massive
massive amount of cash I think we have
like something like a surplus of like 17
billion dollars when we had this storm
which you guys know about this crazy
hurricane uh you know FEMA cut Aid and
then of course Florida had enough money
to cover it Cali deficit uh Heather says
with all the Biden docks unravelings
I've heard a number of other like-minded
Allied independent journalists like
yourself thinking this is all to get
Biden out of office or at least to not
run again my question is given that we
have documented proof that the DS was
planning the pandemic as early as what
2016 maybe earlier wouldn't it stand to
reason that the entirety of Biden's
presidency has also been fairly well
planned out in advance look we can all
go down some level of conspiracy theory
here and you know can conspiracy
theorists the last 10 years on
conspiracy theorists they're looking
pretty good they're certainly looking
better than most
most journalists
and I don't think anything you said
there was like a wild conspiracy theory
you have to remember when Joe Biden was
running and you had you know you had
people to judge and you had Kamala and
you had Tulsi gabbard and you had Bernie
and Elizabeth Warren et cetera Etc
remember right before super Tuesday
super Tuesday's on a Tuesday and if you
remember on that Monday they cut the
deal with everybody they cut the deal so
that Pete dropped out and Bernie dropped
out and Elizabeth Warren dropped out and
Pete got a job in the administration
Bernie's just allowed to keep doing his
nonsensical Bernie thing whatever it is
and they all solidified around Biden
whatever that is what you is it the
Clinton machine the Obama machine like
somebody orchestrated all of that this
is just politics that's not a crazy
conspiracy theorist a theory
um they orchestrated all of that because
it seems to me that whoever they is felt
that the best guy to take out Trump for
whatever reason was Joe Biden my guess
is they did not think Biden was going to
sort of mentally collapse this early the
idea that he could even be considering
running again is so bananas I really
don't think he will do it I I think
there's still a large chance he doesn't
even make it through the end of the term
and and this document stuff is sort of
the perfect way to just push him aside
you have like a temporary Kamala
situation and then you let Gavin in
something like that doesn't that sort of
seem right to you I I don't think the
system has much use for him you may
remember I I've told the story once or
twice that when I met Trump at the
height of impeachment and this was
during you know the Democrats were in
the middle of their campaign and they
were they were all running at the time
uh you may remember those what was it
about three weeks where Mike Bloomberg
was running nobody was supporting Mike
Bloomberg but the media was all about
Mike Bloomberg and in those two debates
that Mike Bloomberg was in you may
remember everybody was attacking him and
I said to Trump I said I said Mr
President my theory on this is that the
only reason Bloomberg is in is because
they want the fire directed at him
because Biden is polling number one and
they know if everyone goes on a date
debate stage and attacks Biden that he's
going to break down he can't deal with
it cognitively or any other way and
Trump kind of laughed at me and he first
of all first he said to Melania he's
like this is sort of interesting listen
to this he had me repeat it to her and
then he's like nah Bloomberg just hates
me but I really think I was right about
that I think the system put Bloomberg in
as a complete he was a horrible
candidate he did not even try there was
no support but they needed to drag bite
into the Finish Line somehow and I think
if you can see some of these tactics
that the machine uses then you don't
fall for them next time so we're gonna
have
you know a big Republican primary coming
up and Nikki Haley has said she's in I'm
hearing that my buddy Larry Elder is
going to get in it sounds like Mike
Pompeo is going to get in there's going
to be an interesting crop of people many
of whom I like and let's see how the
games are a bit different the games will
be different also because Republicans
generally behave a little bit
differently right remember Trump in 2016
he just ran the show all the way through
they kept saying the establishment wants
to stop him but nobody did stop him
nobody coalesced to stop him he took out
Cruz took out Rubio Etc
um so we shall see Memaw says what
happened with Bill Maher when you went
to see him in La this time inquiring
minds want to know so I went to after
San Francisco I was just like I'm in
Cali like how often am I going to get
down here I've got a couple friends I
want to I want to do some stuff with
prageru so I went to real time and I was
backstage which it's sort of like like
quite honestly like it's ridiculous at
this point that I haven't been on the
show but I go backstage and you know
every producer and everyone there
they're all saying hi to me oh yeah it's
so weird you haven't been on the show
yet and I'm just like all right like I
don't I really don't care anymore I'm
not just saying that I don't care
anymore if anything I would almost view
it as a headache if I got the call at
this point I I did what I needed to do
with Bill in those two and a half hours
or whatever it was when we did the club
random podcast
um and and we've become friendly
subsequently so I don't need it it felt
sort of silly you know considering I had
just spent time with Elon it's like I
could have talked about some pretty
relevant stuff
um but there it seems to me they're
maybe going in a different direction or
you know to put a somewhat sane
right-leading person on might be too
much exposure for what they're trying to
do over there whatever it is it does it
doesn't even matter
um bill and I talked about a whole bunch
of stuff that's on the DL okay here we
go uh Nick says once Luke and Justin are
old enough to join the local boys
basketball slash golf team how would you
and David teach them to handle a
situation where one of their teammates
identified as trans that's an
interesting question well first off as I
said I can't wait to get them out there
playing basketball David was a was a
golfer in high school he's a really
great golfer and I'm trying to we're
trying to carve out a little more time
now because he's so in it with the kids
so that he could you know there's
obviously a ton of great golf courses
here in Florida so we're trying to make
that happen
um how would we deal with it well I
guess the first part of that is like
we'll have to see when when the time
comes and hopefully they don't get
confronted with something like that for
quite some time and I think we have some
protections against that obviously here
in Florida and and you know whether we
homeschool or private school or whatever
but but does it seem like the world is
heading in a direction where it is
likely that my seven-year-old son might
know
a girl who's pretending to be a boy or
whatever and like what do you do with
that
think
man I don't know what the right answer
would be yet
I don't know I guess I'm not the parent
of a seven-year-old yet and I'd really
have to think I do when we do talk about
this sort of thing a lot at dinner like
like what you'd want to do and what we
will try to do is is put these kids into
the world without being too muddled in
their minds hopefully knowing what a
loving family is and knowing what
something close to truth is and and
goodnesses and all those things and
surrounded by you know I'm blessed to be
surrounded not only by great family and
friends but like they're gonna have
awesome influence you know Justin's
middle name is Jordan in honor of Jordan
Peterson like hopefully Jordan will have
a little role in his life and and Dennis
Prager and these great people so I think
we can I think we can buttress a lot of
the uh the good ideas we can really
stabilize them so when the crazy stuff
comes in it'll kind of present itself
and we'll know how to deal with it but I
don't know if if Justin came home and he
said I'm in I'm in basketball
and there's a girl who's going by the
name Brian but it really wouldn't be
that direction right it would be the
other way most likely because the little
girl yeah it's messy it's messy I I hey
we're gonna be doing the show in seven
years yeah okay I'll let you know Nathan
says uh I've been a supporter since
Rogan helped you launch the girl could
help me launch I've been on Rogan a
couple times I don't know if you helped
me launch but all right uh it's been a
wild ride question will you support
starting a funding campaign to send Sam
Harris mail order desserts until he
agrees to talk to Brett Weinstein for at
least an hour you know look I addressed
the Sam thing earlier in the week I told
you it didn't give me any great pleasure
but I sort of felt that I had to do it
to like kind of get it out of my system
and because so many people ask me about
it
um it is very disappointing and if you
listen to the video that we played uh
where Sam you know he's still kind of
going after like mocking Brett for being
vaccine skeptical and it's like no Sam
you should have been but also even if
Sam felt that Brett was completely wrong
on vaccine skepticism which again
clearly Brett was right right clearly I
was right clearly many of you were right
why wouldn't you talk to him about it
the whole idea when we started the IDW
was that we were all it was this
wide-ranging people I always used when
people ask me what the whole IDW was you
know this group of people we it's hard
to remember because it was five or six
years ago now and the internet moved so
fast but it was this really wide swath
of people that that had very very
different views on things that were
coming together and talking about all
the important issues it was almost we
were just on the early end of seeing how
wokeness was going to destroy so much
and we were trying to stop that from
happening that really is what it boiled
down to but I always used Sam and Ben
Shapiro as as the the example of what
this thing really was because salmon Ben
Shapiro literally disagreed on
everything on everything I would say
except sort of the basic tenets of the
United States meaning they disagreed on
belief and religion and God they
disagreed on abortion and taxes and and
virtually every political you know
Democrats versus Republicans like pretty
much everything you could think of but
but they often would sit down in my
garage in our studio and talk it out and
we would agree that we all wanted to
live in the same country so that was the
beautiful thing so the disappointing
part with Sam is that he suddenly didn't
want to talk to any of his friends or
the people that were willing to talk
about these things and that as I said
the other day was disappointing to me at
a at a personal level more than a
professional level I didn't care if we
did any of this stuff publicly I really
didn't and I always would say that and
I've said that to many many friends over
the years who who were angered or
disappointed with my politics or they
see me with a picture with Trump or an
event with DeSantis and they they think
I'm this right-wing maniac and it's like
man can you not separate friendship put
aside whether we agree or disagree
politically can you not separate that
from Friendship
why can I do it why do I consistently
find that people on the right are able
to do that and people on the left are
not well I think there's actually a very
fundamental reason for that having to do
with belief and the lack of belief I
think was making Sam feel very tenuous
in everything he said so he didn't want
to be confronted with people that maybe
got things right or saw things a little
bit differently oh it is what it is
something like that
um lady broad says Dave is there ever
going to be a republican conservative
party that will unify like the Democrats
even for irresponsible stupid bills they
stick together it's powerful yeah well
the quest tip for power will get you to
stick together right if your goal is not
like what's right or what's just it's
just like we want more power we want
more power over people we want more of
their money to do what we want to them
it's like you can unify against that
what do they say you go to a Libertarian
contest uh conference and it's like it's
like herding cats right because
everybody's got their own issue they're
like pet issue that they really care
about whether it's dry legalization of
driver's licenses or what should happen
with hardcore drugs or the Border or all
these things so once you get people
that believe in individual rights that
that respect autonomy of the mind of the
self and you try to get them to
coordinate themselves into a political
party and make a coherent you know if
you're asking about the Republican party
then you'd want them to have a coherent
set of values and that when the next
presidential election rolls out that's
what they do at the convention they say
here are the principles of our party and
the principles of our party let's say as
the Republican Party those are going to
be different than say pure conservative
principles right those are going to be
different than pure libertarian
principles but what you want to do is
you want to create the widest tense so
enough people can get in there I think
I'm a living breathing example of this
as someone that is a duly rep registered
Republican here in Florida I think this
is the wide tent party I think it
probably has been for a long time it was
a little hard to see as the mainstream
media didn't want you to see it but that
will be the challenge maybe it can't
hold like maybe I'm being a little uh
you know rose-colored glasses sort of
thing in what I see as being this wide
party but I really do think it is and I
think I have enough evidence of that not
only because of what I do here and that
we see the response that you guys give
us but I literally travel the country
and meet people from every Walk of Life
whether it's whether it's some guy in
Arkansas
or it's a disaffected you know a
traditional conservative let's say in
Arkansas or it's a disaffected liberal
and Cali and it's like boy you guys
disagree about some stuff but I know you
both love America I know you both
respect free speech I know you like rule
of law and you think that this whole
experiment is good and worthy fighting
for so that's what we that's the
challenge and whether we can actually do
it is well the the proof is in the
pudding Kathy says what are your plans
for off the great August now that the
boys are here Kathy I don't know but I
really really do hope that we're able to
get away for a little bit
um actually uh you know fortunately
because we we've both got family on the
East Coast hopefully we can get some
family members some grandparents to come
on down and maybe take the kids for a
little bit we used to do some great
trips and we've gone to the to the
Amazon and Mexico and we did the Bora
Bora thing and just disconnect none of
this and I just stare at the ocean I
don't need to read a book I try to read
some on the planes but like I can just
sit if you get me on a beach I can just
sit down David drives him crazy because
he's got books he's got his e-reader
he's got he's looking at it uh well not
looking at his phone but he's just like
got his well he's got like the iPad for
reading
magazines all that stuff and I could
just sit there I literally can just sit
there and watch the waves and it could
be six hours later I've eaten some
Ceviche I've had a little tequila I'm
good to go
um that that works for me
um I I hope we can get away a little bit
you know the thing that happens with
August is like there's so many places
that I want to go back to I really want
to go back to Italy I haven't been there
since 1997 I was 21 I was basically
broke kind of backpacking through Europe
didn't have a great appreciation for
food or wine or anything else like I was
eating at McDonald's in Rome like I
would love to go back to Italy just for
the just for the food
um I really want to go back to Australia
I've never been to Japan that's really
number one on my list of places that I
want to go that I haven't been to
um and then we're going to tell you a
bit more on that question about the
European tour in a bit because it does
look like some places that I have not
been to yet anyway that is the show for
today we're gonna have you guys stick
around for the post game show on locals
if you want to ask a couple extra
questions or get some comments in there
if you haven't subscribed please do so
at rumble.com
report part two of my interview with the
Willy Wonka of politics Michael malis is
up right now on YouTube and Rumble the
full things up at locals I leave you
with Elizabeth Warren complaining about
Elon Musk see you in 37 seconds
every American citizen who does outworks
for a living and pays taxes and is
paying more than Elon Musk who most
recently 2018 paid zero in taxes that's
just fundamentally wrong
[Music]